Islam's front kick up the middle is a
new uh wrinkle I like that I like that
move so he's made some adjustments and
there's a shot stuffed look at this
volovski is initiating the clinch here
look at this volkanovski is trying to
take him down vul is pressuring him up
against the cage and he's trying to take
him down release the tie clinch and
shoot it's what most guys would do okay
this front kick up the body that was a
round kick up the
body [__] oh Jesus oh Jesus oh Jesus
he's out oh my God what
theal God he head kicked oh my God oh my
God he head kicked now you'll never see
that fight again that's the risk that's
the risk B God what a shocker wow what a
shocker you still we're even now God
damn